how do you understand this
are you trying to
[Laughter]
okay trying to be oh you don't need we
don't need Griffin's already because I
would be hosting it remember when I
didn't have any audio it goes through
one person's audio I figure it out I
mean are we doing this for all of them
so boom there we go all right cool you
know shadowboxing what to play twitch to
go on your podcast yes
[Music]
[Music]
two weeks we can do Steve's going to the
bridge
so even though I don't hear my twisted
is some weird people watching I think
they might I think they're able to see
that it's the game switch but I think
for us when I owe something in like yeah
double hand cannon thank you
[Laughter]
[Music]
the dialogue room hey you should have
been dead Dempsey oh sit down I'm just
[ __ ] destroying these guys oh my god
this [ __ ] sword always my friend oh
wait we kill this count oh [ __ ] [ __ ] me
on that got to be you can't be getting
ready to do this
what exactly are you getting ready to
view all right better control oh this
games on this or you have a good game oh
that's great we could play six yeah
[Music]
to be forgiving like neck-and-neck
[ __ ] always good I don't care unreal
that one doesn't count [ __ ]
because we were trying to fix our audio
exactly well I get Frank wants to jump
in you can't play together
okay yeah that's what we can do it by
the way god of war freaking amazing
really is it good yeah it's really no no
I'm just telling you it's [ __ ]
amazing damn we got so we owe it is all
to this is it I'm going
a love for comedy just that's awesome
dude take some good pictures it's like
how bad is Japanese comedy I'm not
crashing I'm just you know featuring at
least they're flying out there though
[Music]
I'm just gonna go to all the bathhouses
now are you gonna bring some [ __ ] No
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
the whole time if I pass you on the
street or wave to you piece of [ __ ] I'm
going straight to be there's no one with
me and
swinging down to the cherry stuff what
are you using you've no Dulles yep
vigilance wing it's better not at all go
ahead
the showerhead dude
oh he asked if he could get some naked
pictures of Craig and I said no problem
doesn't yeah I don't think anybody wants
that yeah I wouldn't wish that on my
worst a mad warlock no don't get it try
to go just try and keep see yeah we're
here yeah but it [ __ ] the spawn up
though is what I'm saying I know
yep come right back to see well it took
be anyway so yeah well don't go crazy
no but that's response once we once we
get a it switches our sponsor to the
other side that's where we get fun
well I'm saying we're not gonna get
[ __ ] cuz you're here with us you're
killing me because that's what one's one
end is the complete opposite so wait
when we take a we spawn back here every
time
and then we get [ __ ] winning because
they're closer to C and B that's a you
never right now yep oh damn I mean I
mean don't listen to me I you know I
don't know what I'm talking about
well yeah we know that yeah we're gonna
happen it's gonna be I'm just they're
pushing me
okay did you die yeah sure if your main
and then I died cuz I'll push me I'm
coming I'm coming colas I'm coming
towards you
let's go we're taking game swap around
let's push let's push yeah yeah where's
that orb damn it
and that's how you get around that is we
need to I mean get me though you [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh my god
well somebody help me this dudes just
hide line up like a tree god damn it
dude meaning [ __ ] guns am I using I got
one hurt enemy I'm going that way yeah
there we go alright we're gives us lon I
need help
oh yeah there we go
I'm getting hurt alright you're getting
heavy my game there's one hurt you put
up a shield in that corner I got nice
yep I'm gonna take C I'm gonna get the
guy off C demolishing that guy should be
[ __ ] dead this guy's the worst a
[ __ ] just I got snipers using now cuz
we got a power play good
Steve it's like a basketball you know it
uses a basketball the same they're on
see I'm using my Titan and I want to go
warlock slam Titan next time I don't
understand how you should go [ __ ]
storm collar with that heart soul man
that's just [ __ ] dope and six they
take him back yeah they're all they get
see let's get C let's get you know I see
oh he tried his storm yeah
that need work too good for a mom oh I
got he's dead yes got no he got another
dead after after everybody actually got
killed oh my god this is a nightmare I
got there calling me guy too
well we're about to have a colony guy me
do it
well I don't know where they are I'm
coming to be storm trans coming to be
[ __ ] it oh my - listo gone for see with
our and these are random it means a
random because their their gamertag is
EMU when they're not in your party
I'm you just I need to switch just
completely they don't need to do this
isn't working
they're taking taking see singing b-plus
you didn't say thing about his
explanation she like
yeah when you see when you see a player
that's not in your party yeah okay you
had that the whole time you let me die
no I just killed that guy just picked it
up and then I shot those guys out there
there I'll be okay somebody killing it
huh
just like getting these dudes love them
you know I got switched my gun on should
have been should have been doing better
one more damn it
then do spike supers are so useless if
they can just team okay
my KB is sitting around maybe a little
higher than a 2.0 like if I put what if
I put on my if I put on my my KD emblem
it's sitting at a two point six five but
that's KD a
so that's assists - so it's like a -
[ __ ]
KT that's really good isn't it yeah at
one point I was hard it's good actually
yeah Craig seems better but he also sees
guys they don't play with people like
Craig every night when you play with
Craig every now
you don't even play your good character
with us anymore
yeah I literally I know what he means is
I made a character not to play with you
guys but this is the character then I
told
Kennecott this is the character this is
the character that I said I was making
not to play with crank but i I've been
playing with Craig with this character
for like two months so I don't want to
hear him bitching because I did make a
character but [ __ ] sons of [ __ ] I
was trying to tell you the whole story
and you just for them turn me in the
bath I don't
no dude I play with arrow and all arrows
the guys that arrow people you guys okay
no you [ __ ] no the foreign guys
let's go to be all my [ __ ] my guys not
running guys I might be outside me
you just can't kill anyone I got one
watch out Frank Phoenix yep you got
Craig shoulder guy over there oh oh nice
Griffin Griffin fusing the man oh thank
you I'm not gonna take it I'm just gonna
kill them I'm gonna take you right we
don't want to take that should have been
a three down
let's call it rock age I call it
whatever I want bro he calls our
electricity all right they're coming
get back get back you see right there
there we go nice they gotta come to us
so far
nice good team Chad's coming around he's
waiting for heavy the wall up I need
help yeah I got heavy got one yep nice
nice Frank let's go there we go all
right we're probably gonna flip spawns
so they might start responding around a
how do you understand the spawn thing I
don't understand
Steve for like two seconds you sounded
like yeah okay I thought there is no
correct me if I'm wrong all right dude
what the [ __ ] I made this party invite
[Laughter]
so I it was it really was to give us a
foot coach said it was your question
how do you understand spawn flips are
you trying to be more masculine or
further away from where your opponent is
so like if you if you if you go to the
complete other side most likely they're
gonna say Heather it is not my map I
like thank you oh that didn't kill him
oh they're so hurt on B bro beat loss so
her alright that was so so saying I had
a chance I didn't take it any of the
afternoon
hey there's a slam back here seems to
them
oh yeah he's coming at me comes down
there you go Griffin you're using a hand
cannon yeah baby what do you wanna say
more exotic 100 the Crimson that's right
yeah don't call oh just come and watch
out hi they don't call it to me
well it's just electricity everywhere
our tech to have me out i thump out of
the storm
oh god oh we need to just get Dean boys
yeah we gotta get B they're kind of
creeping back here he's got a shotgun
nice Craig okay
I'm gonna see he's almost down yes
oh let's catch got a shotgun just get me
god damn vigilance wings man I might go
to my vigilance winks to one's got a
sword this world life Griffin he's
chasing you they're gonna catch up got
two specials I was trying to get away
you have a web of a bunch of crazy
person yeah there's no [ __ ] sense
all right guys he did you get back here
all that guy had a sword still go and be
that we all need to push here because uh
oh yeah yeah yeah to get more points cuz
they have more songs together yeah I'm
getting team shot like a [ __ ]
right now this is we're taking down
there he's picking up pieces and mo
probably [ __ ] there's a guy coming to
see he's gonna she's gonna sign man
that's the shotgun day keep be zone he's
running around the worst [ __ ] oh he's
telling history he got out he's slamming
he's slamming oh I checked it we should
go
[Music]
Oh
hammers Spock these orbs [ __ ] hammers
dude [ __ ] you
hammers over B everything over B go for
B if the heavy I'm going to be yesterday
I kept this dude are fake
get me over beat get him to come to beat
come to beat they're coming to be nice
Steve good team shot he's hurt over
there you get him oh no I got this tight
thank you
they're going for a storm
he's hurt no [ __ ] oh god he's hurt so
hurt i'll be there you go nice Griffin
dip st one more kill
we got it
nice house a beautiful wall that is
crazy
you did it that was crazy
oh look damn Craig Craig Shady
look at that JD Steve sees Katy
he's like switching stick redesign his
controller mid-game your face that was a
good game that's close we brought back
that was fun yeah I don't think you got
you didn't capture any other zones
what's going on Frank supposed to be
done so much I might be this map is
really little
watch our left here oh [ __ ] there's a
grenade
oh I didn't even [ __ ] see that [ __ ]
there's guy come here get behind me on
it oh we didn't get me I don't know
there's a guy he's taking a whole bike
[Music]
I'm gonna get heavy and push for me no I
guess I'm not whatever
help me push me very took it to salvage
I got one [ __ ]
we're all there yeah we got that guy
nice game jack nice bready we're gonna
get me I cannot believe I survived that
oh I didn't survive it
nice rocket both sword
[ __ ] to aggressive something push get
that heavy I'm gonna go to be I'm on sea
by myself just trying to keep them away
and there's a guy with a sword there oh
my god he got me see I'm too aggressive
I'm just jumping in there [ __ ] eight
people at a time
nice Frank we can switch guns
let's get be bad nice yep all right what
was this okay from the side and vis on
beef sores that [ __ ] sword guy needs
to go needs to [ __ ] go
he's just sitting around the bed in the
corner
alright good alright Frank's got that
heavy I need help
I'm gonna be he's hurt oh I'm gonna go
colony I'm going to see I'm going see
that Colin is so cheap dude that's a
cheap girl it's so cheap so my go-to
baby just gotta time it look at Frank
though you're just a heavy hoarder over
here
the heavy hoarder it Sambi there you go
nicely okay they can read it to a wall
trying to get away from oh I got the
Asian guy that was good what's our guy's
got Dom Blaine I got him Oh got to go
guys to need more points we should I
need help there you go ice good job
Stevie on a five coke on a five it gets
into the pants stuff right when I was
coming out of [ __ ] team shot that base
Oh yep just like that good [ __ ] boys huh
so tight yes all right I got see I'm
going okay
it's gonna it's gonna watch the slam
today oh hey hey sit down a one-guy
alright there we go now let's roll
together to be Denham Griffin the guys
see just get they're gonna come what is
that
all right cart behind us good
he almost got the whole team with that
[ __ ] he almost caught up with that that
was the guy kill don't kill him oh my
god these are so tired of being in last
place of this [ __ ] game
your first place in our heart Griffin
there's a Golden Gun
not anymore hey ah [ __ ] Hera leave a
Havanese how the [ __ ] did he survive the
rotten gone soon because the order have
two swords sword there too
I'll just shoot that nothing watch out
why didn't that kill him damn it I'm
popping the super at me dad agreed
you're heavy
I got three more long ago see oh yeah
we're all these orbs at ah I got a sword
guy sitting got sword guy we got the
lead dumb these rings
yeah I got me you gotta come back we
gotta come back
we gotta get zones you got get zone they
got all of what is that the [ __ ] zone
not only just lose if you get their ass
beat we were at one point for a long
time it slam watch all right nice we
can't let them get one kill
[Music]
you're building a bridge
[Laughter]
throw something at the wall
[Music]
Oh
Oh
let's get B I'm gonna try and keep these
guys off this way all right I'm coming
I'm coming B I'm coming mmm that drag
shot it's just so greasy captured your
lead grow sharper oh I just jumped off a
[ __ ] popular here's [ __ ] pop your
crucible wins when you can touch the
switch - no I like this one better
oh yeah I'm gonna go to my warlock and
go on a the [ __ ] would
oair oh my I hate you in the rocket is
too aggressive like I just not good at
this game
Robocop 19 20 wish I have my [ __ ] I'm
over here but they're coming they're
coming though I'm hearing like the echo
somebody oh those thing yeah I have to
now turn down their TV turn down here -
I'm here if somebody feed somebody on
Twitter their TV turn it down oh oh
that's me look at Jesus epic fail
damn heroes guy with him it was how can
I hit that guy we gotta go together
where are we going let's pick this on
and go for gonna be it spawned me by
this oh yeah I don't know what I'm doing
killing us gonna be about to give this
smoke I'm at beat that's too nice
shotgun on me hammers oh my god straight
to be Oh
nice slam all that kill that such that's
what I'm saying it's [ __ ] like all
of a sudden I slam into them and they so
not tell me well because they can't
punch you I know but it's ridiculous
the problem is investigate your slam you
have to be full health that's the thing
we're kind of bringing on help my guy
would decide to run I agree oh my god
we're bringing back their mobile bomb
like a piece of [ __ ] gettin arrows he's
right there behind the walk rock
I'll give me this nice okay war cliff
coil let me see Craig yeah you know when
I'm being hurt you know what you know
what's weird about the war cliff coil
like you only have one and they kill you
I got it off but it's like I dropped
heavy stone don't make no sense
yeah that's weird
yeah and I just picked it up that see
yeah they're spawning watch out shotgun
shotgun
here it come to you oh my god dude like
supers are useless they're just [ __ ]
useless man and they feel like a
long-range one that's thank you that was
such spawn kill [ __ ] you start
shooting him before it was just a
clearly Jesus what is [ __ ] cap who is
that there we aren't going gun oh my god
so good such good timing
yeah [ __ ] you
stupid-ass shield
where are they I got to work with
they're all okay everybody see that on
camera
did you see what I just did camera like
that was Flula to order like that was
some nonsense what I just did
like I need to just not play anymore
like that was a worthy of not you need
to push up is what you need to do
further man who is Nova pass me you know
what I'm gonna go I'm gonna be [ __ ] you
I'm gonna be a bubble next time dad kill
me at our staff at the animal was
chasing me you guys feel about sixes
look at Steve no has he got a better KD
then both me and Aero D way to you oh
yeah you killed it Steve
yeah makes you wonder what Errol and
coke are doing it's just coming from the
mouth of Craig
let me let me pull up the story I
stirred lower screaming Craig really
contributed with his point six
what you stupid you've killed it
Steve NAB you can be happy for Steve I'm
happy for see does it me yeah in life
Steve not at all
it means matters in the game so it means
you got double the kills the amount of
times you die so you you didn't give up
deaths
so you didn't give the team very many
points and you got us a bunch of points
and ready player wants us you get the
key first so Craig wait Craig - Craig
way try point ninja so that what that
means is he died more times than you
guys know any Cal yeah so he he actually
gave up he gave up more points to the
enemy team your team now if you have
negative KT yes okay yes it hurt here's
someone or if you get 0 kills I like
that you were doing it the whole time
do you see Griffin on the jumbotron
he just dancing around yeah Titan time
I thought you followed everything for
what's my god are you real
yeah the real most yeah somebody said
she'll break our a word we're just gonna
ignore beat beat just go yeah let's go
see now who's going okay let's go afraid
they're gonna spawn us so wait wait a
second
one's hurt coming down through the
middle I'm gonna have advantage opponent
claims own be in the dark II think this
[ __ ] invincible ass wall dude this
wait
why don't I kill myself Jesus Christ man
that I can't tell you it is weird though
gonna drop we gotta go to Tel Aviv again
lit I'm popping that oh no we're not
going over to be I was just killing a
dude Frank's not working with the team
here as usual per use he's coming coming
for a coming around come on Brae yep
there's two of them there's two of them
got to hurt so they got swords be
careful just [ __ ] to be lose egg
we're not even going over to be they
jump they use that [ __ ] teleporter
thing
[ __ ] your sword [ __ ] thank you that's
what I think of it kill myself myself
every time I've used it like literally
every time I use it I kill myself
Oh [ __ ] goody kill axel no doodahs
riding it right no I got killed by that
guy with an axe on board one that makes
no sense there oh my god maybe there's
more I have full help that's it just it
makes sense
we just a CDC I just can't get here oh
my god there's a guy be with I don't
know how that was at least they're all
there nice
oh there's any more orders oh there's a
major echo and it's not me hear that -
whose TV's on it's not mine that's on TV
i think i think it's a delay on the
[ __ ] commute on the on the test and i
thought can you guys hear an echo people
on the chat I don't hear it now it comes
and it goes
I don't know what's up yeah it's weird
you tell it on that Stevie Rose that
Nova ah [ __ ]
they missed our if and make sure nobody
yeah didn't get me I said I killed
somebody with my [ __ ] war clip
[Music]
[ __ ] weird bro they're gone see I'm
gone see how many of them are there oh
they're taking a [ __ ] they're gonna have
a power play oh I got a sword - oh my
god I'm taking B I'm happy I'm taking it
we need something general now that's
yeah and then now we're now we're all
over here at B because of that no we
were gonna be so that's where it spawned
me dude we're all gonna get spawn there
anyway sword guys over here
careful
oh my god oh you know what I mean I
think you suppressor grenades forgot
about that guy
nice Oh hammer gets Heather and I have a
bubble all right wait to use it let's
let's show their mist we got these two
points
AHA [ __ ] yeah I save it Griffin for
when they when they capture wanna raise
their seeds and then we can [ __ ] put
that he's gonna get he's gonna go to a
little bread bubbled on a who did your
first I wish I didn't do anything
oh my god that was just we gotta go for
we got to go for see see see they're
coming they're Vic two of them Etsy
oh now we're all spawned on your feed
you got that bubble course in Vegas [ __ ]
I was now they're all moving as a unit
they're all moving towards the heavy
together five minutes that bubbled up
well he just killed him with a [ __ ]
sword how did he do that your bubbles
he's still come in no I don't
I got a I got a sword guy take care I'm
going to hold down see what the [ __ ] is
oh my god oh wow
I can't wait to see the Chinese right
there coke yeah put up a few bubble
right now we put up a seal I brought up
a field down
why are you here [ __ ] have to
get CMAC yeah or no I'm going to see if
you gotta get watch you couple big ever
heavy
[Laughter]
I can't believe I'm a [ __ ] rocket wait
we know we need seven kills for seven
points we're fine they're about to take
a demolished us no opening this mountain
my arrows mouth hi wow I'm just I can't
my gun doesn't work like everybody
else's work this is the most
embarrassing thing they ever happened in
the history of destiny
oh and again I think I haven't even done
it you know what level the second level
right you can't get spotted
yeah I know I'm awesome in the mood for
that tonight either little walks ooh
nice
the one person in my chat is saying raid
because there's no one else in my chat
we just do the beginning part the
beginning parts the bass is probably the
easiest remember the first one had
weapons works weapons just doing this
right
[Music]
okay and I've got maybe ten master rates
from trials which means they jump higher
from the raise well you spray it like
twenty twenty cords no I have thirty
right now and I actually infuse stuff
earlier so I was sitting there like yeah
43 from trials you get a lot - I got
fifty one quarter right now from trials
in the raid yeah just by winning by
participating a winning somebody much
others named faith
[Music]
rush hour 2 over you in rush hour to our
CB CB I might be right now
[Music]
alright Griffin number one that won't
last
oh my god that's oh yeah [ __ ] they're
all coming B so [ __ ] watch out watch out
oh [ __ ]
happy stupid you walk to my grenade oh
my god yeah power play
there they got ripped on me pretty
firing up was this ridiculous I don't
understand like I'm plain ice why'd the
bus stop it Celeste oh thanks I hope
whoever did that
behind us this guy's trying to [ __ ] with
me when it comes to Hank and it's not
gonna work that's another non phony
Jules total control how about you help
I'm [ __ ] hell I'm doing oh damn I
can't believe that racket didn't [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah yeah
[Music]
[Music]
I click BB to engage in my role my
disappearing role and then it improves
if you read my stats it improves my
weapon handling for a short time so with
my mind it's already good but then it's
like really crisp you know oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
studying that's that's what that's what
prime most those guys do and then
increases their movement as well as
their weapon handling
oh yeah a lot of Stevie I mean from his
music I mean from his music from the
music from DVD si
as a Gilbert Gilbert Gilbert I think
he's guilty of Gilbert from from
Achilles
oh my god
oh they're spawning back because you're
on see they [ __ ] me Jesus
god dammit this scout rifle sucks too
what's got your right I'm just trying to
make you kid sometimes Griffin plays
slave kills it just depends I'm like
Griffin when we play it when we play it
without the tool all we do better
that's funny yeah it's the way it is
it's cuz what it is is like you probably
just watching me and Griffin the whole
time you're getting the pickup tears
[Music]
and so far is a wiving mr. beard versus
invisible piece of [ __ ] when I got this
is their plan to just stay all the way
back there and all those a good rocket
that was a [ __ ] you rocket right there
they can see I'm taking they're trying
to get be certain advantages yes go
ahead
you look please oh [ __ ]
hey guys get behind me oh my god this is
just a nightmare
oh good job thank you that's saving kill
I think this [ __ ] mercy get Jesus
Christ thank you
outlet what do you say one more and then
yeah just one more a little more lunar
aid cool yeah we're doing Calais
prestige oh yeah I don't even know I
gotta go guys
how do you do that how do you do count I
don't need I've never done prestige they
air oh you're gonna come to our festival
screening in LA what is it where is it
how much is it May 13th
I'll get your free ticket if you come
out all the tickets are free Craig let's
be real 18 bucks a ticket that's not no
that's what I'm saying what so I say if
you need help getting tickets let me
know so when did they fill in the movie
was it it's like over 10 years old right
quick 20 years ago
Wow 20 years ago but we cut it together
now do you look the same
I'm not in it I'm out in it I just cut
help cut it together and do all stuff
work
I've never been in a movie not that
anybody ever asked yeah it should be fun
I got a lot of fun coming out Chris is
coming for Steve what about Oh Christmas
what about land I'm trying to see
George's come and dance brother I don't
know about lands I'm waiting to hear all
right this is it come on yeah do the
[ __ ] out again I doubt they care I know
but be funny if somebody's like yeah on
Twitter says definitely too at worst
fire team ever hashtag warlock hashtag
runner at second place hot tonight Steve
my place kind of hot too hot
our CV I don't think he counts this map
just kind of keep revolving clean it's
just like a big circle and keep spawn on
that girl
I always start Gilles and now I'm in
first
[ __ ] that guy damnit [ __ ] Moulton it's
a stupid round
so I'll just yeah over there in that
corner is this the same team probably we
almost like a full and almost look like
a full team oh my god zones
okay [ __ ] anymore my gun is never gonna
work cuz I'm not gonna try anymore
[Laughter]
yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] watch your orbs over the asset
yeah god I was like I was coming around
on my telesco then it was like I mean
this is the same team we're gonna merge
yeah they're not even playing stupid
tricks I'll show them together well
they're at sea wait where - [ __ ] see I'm
gonna put on this hi you ass fall back
that's golden Doug head on with a trip
how we mercy them yeah I do one more
that's a lie
the best way demolishing a team is the
lack way to end it what the [ __ ] you
wanna challenge
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]